[موسيقى]
هنا بيت حانون في اقصى شمالي قطاع غزه
البلده سكنها حتى وقت قريب اكثر من 50 الف
نسمه سيطرت عليها قوات الاحتلال منتصف
ديسمبر الماضي وسوت احياء كامله في
المدينه
بالارض بتفجيرات متعمده كما تظهر الصور
وليس فقط بالقصف
الجوي
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
هذه هي بلده بيت حنون على الخريطه جيب
صغير اقصى شمال شرق
القطاع المناطق الحمراء هي التي تعرضت
لدمار كلي او شبه كلي في البلده بحسب صور
اقمار
صناعيه وهي مثال لما يجري على كامل
القطاع يقتصر تدمير المباني في قطاع غزه
على حرمان السكان من منازلهم او الطلاب من
حقهم في التعليم او المرضى من حقهم في
الاستشفاء وليس من العدل النظر لاي عمليه
تدمير منهجيه بوصفها جريمه حرب فقط بحسب
خبراء في القانون
الدولي فتدمر المباني دومي سيد هو من
اشكال قتل المجتمعات والذاكره الج عيه
لهذه المجتمعات بحسب مقرر الامم المتحده
للحق بسكن
لائق حي الزهراء بمدينه غزه يعرف بابرا
العاليه حي راق يصفه السكان بانه مخصص
للموظفين من الطبقه المتوسطه العليا كان
يعيش فيه اكثر من 5000 شخص بات ركاما يضاف
الى ذلك ما كشفته صحيفتها ارتس بان الجنود
يدمرون بعض المباني في غزه باضرام النيران
فيها بناء على اوامر مباشره من
قادتهم وهذه مدينه غزه على الخريطه وحي
الزهراء بشكل اكثر تحديدا يقول البنك
الدولي ان
34 الف منزل دمرت بالك
من بين
55 الفا وهي من المناطق الاشد تاثرا بنسبه
دمار تصل لنحو 60 في
تقريبا تتهم صحيفه الجارديان البريطانيه
قوات الاحتلال بتسليح المباني والمنشات في
قطاع غزه اي بالتعامل معها على اساس انها
كيان مسلح وتنقل عن خبراء قولهم ان
اسرائيل تدمر بشكل ممنهج مواقع التراث
الثقافي
للفلسطينيين ونسيج الحضري اليومي محاكاه
حجم الضربات الاسرائيليه على قطاع غزه من
حيث التركز الجغرافي والمساحه تجعل خريطه
ذاك الشريط الساحلي تبدو بهذا الشكل فعند
جمع اجزاء القصه الماساويه خلال الاشهر
الماضيه
ستكتسب كما الديموغرافيا لون
احمر المساحات الحمراء هي المناطق التي
استهدفت ودمرت بشكل كلي او جزئي يقدر
البنك الدولي ان قرابه
45% من المباني السكنيه في القطاع دمرت
بشكل كامل اي ان قرابه مليون شخص فقدوا
منازلهم
كليا من بين امور اكثر
ايلاما فقدها سكان
خه